yeah I think the the narratives that we
get from fiction or they're very
confusing to people you know
particularly people that are very
romantic they have these ideas that
their life is going to be like one of
their favorite films and that's what
they're looking for they're holding out
you know they're holding out for when
the music plays and the close-up is
there and and those stories stop going
out to this guy and a baton you read a
lovely book on this those fit the
trouble with those films and those
stories they stop when the people fall
in love and get together yeah that's but
that's when it starts that's when the
tough stuff starts that we could do with
some good strong fictional frameworks
just as you know absorb that that's when
the tough start it's like it's like
death is the same thing as n't it we
have no we've kind of lost touch with
the cultural narratives around death
that gave it some meaning so now when it
happens it's just this absurd scary
thing that we don't know what to do with
the only narrative we have that we have
absorbed I guess is that of the the
brave battle that someone's fighting
which is no one helpful for the person
that's in that situation makes everyone
else maybe feel better but just adds
like eventual failure and letting
everyone else down to this person's
burdens it was what they should what
they should what we should feel in that
at that time is you know that this is
this is when we can bring our if we have
the opportunity to bring our stories to
some kind of ending you know if you
watch a if you watch a film or read a
book
that final scene make sense of
everything that's happened before this
doesn't happen in life it is kind of end
so we we should be like author of our
stories more than at any point before
death and we have the opportunity what
happens is the opposite we become like
cameos in this story you know the main
characters are our loved ones or the
doctors or people making all these
decisions and we kind of get sidelined
so yeah these fictional or mythical
stories just these things that just give
us a sense of where our experience fits
into a wider sense of meaning we've you
know we've we've kind of lost touch with
out the last couple of hundred years and
there's a lot of good stuff that's come
with that because we've embraced you
know science and knowledge at the
expense of superstition of course but I
you know we've kind of lost touch of
something so we've lost a little bit of
touch with nature and the the natural
laws of things living and dying and
I think we as human beings today are
probably more alienated from
particularly the death of farm animals
and things along those lines like where
where food comes from actually seeing
death even if your dog is sick you bring
them to the vet the vet puts them down
you know all these things that people
probably experience firsthand for
hundreds and hundreds of years
particularly like raising animals and
that agenda is just completely removed
from the equation for most folks